let's meet the 53 year-old Massachusetts
woman who became the winner the largest
Powerball jackpot ever won with a single
ticket in history Mavis swans acclaimed
the nearly seven hundred sixty million
dollar prize yesterday and Jericka
Duncan is at the store in Chicopee where
Juan zyk made the purchase changed her
life Jericka good morning
yeah good morning we're hearing that
police have been keeping a watchful eye
over 1-6 home not too far from here but
it all started here at this convenience
store where Juan's occur just three
tickets to work quickfix and one the
winning ticket was a combination of
birthdays and one very lucky number I
need some rest
I'm overwhelmed after a whirlwind day
Mavis Juan's ik returned home seven
hundred fifty eight point seven million
dollars richer I'm so like this isn't
sure this can't be and then now it's
like I am a winner it was a friend who
told her she had the winning Powerball
ticket I go hey I haven't I have that I
have that let me see that ticket he goes
you just want first number up tonight is
seven the mother of two said she picked
random birthdays the Powerball four is a
number her family typically plays on
Friday night keno games map a dream has
finally come true and one's retiring 12
anything early lottery officials caught
some initial confusion when they wrongly
said the winning ticket was sold in
Watertown on the other side of the state
this was the result of a human error
after clearing things up they introduced
wands ik to a room full of reporters
rather than receive her winnings in 30
annual payments the 53 year old has
chosen a single lump sum of 480 million
dollars after taxes she's taking home
336 million a lot of people will be
coming at her in order to try to
recommend all sorts of different things
that she can do with her money
Wan's except she's already quit her
hospital job after 32 years and will pay
off a car she bought just last year but
her plans beyond that are unclear I'm
going to go hide in my bed
[Laughter]
even with 336 million dollars get this
it is not enough to put wands ik on
Forbes top 400 richest Americans it's
not even enough to put her on the top
fifty wealthiest people in Massachusetts
Gail we all love us some Mavis here in
the studio but you know it was happy for
Mavis Deborah Goldberg the lottery
official who was like why Mavis aside
the whole time that's a great story love
it love it love her